opositor a la dictadura convertida en
dirigente de un país acusado de
genocidio aún son sus y se encuentra
arrestada desde el golpe militar de este
febrero y afronta cargos que en total le
podrían dar más de dos décadas de
prisión e inhabilitarla en las futuras
elecciones prometidas por la junta nació
en rangún en 1945 hija de un conocido
comandante durante la guerra de
independencia del imperio británico que
fue asesinado cuando ella tenía dos años
aunque son sus y estudió en inglaterra
donde más tarde se instaló hasta
regresar a mianmar en 1988 por temas
familiares encontró a un país en plena
revuelta fuertemente reprimido por el
gobierno militar fue entonces cuando su
xiv decidió entrar en política y formar
la liga nacional para la democracia en
1989 fue detenida y asignada a arresto
domiciliario dos años más tarde recibió
el premio nobel de la paz entre
múltiples reconocimientos
internacionales finalmente fue liberada
en 2010 y en 2012 elegida diputada
debemos aprovechar la oportunidad de
reformar el país si la perdemos la
historia nos considerara culpables
en 2015 la liga ganó por mayoría las
elecciones legislativas un año más tarde
fue nombrada consejera especial del
estado y pasó a cabo dirigir el país
junto con el ejército una acción
reprobada por sus apoyos internacionales
en particular por la persecución
sistémica de los rohingyas minoría
musulmana en llamar a manos de las
fuerzas armadas al menos 700.000
personas fueron desplazadas forzosamente
hacia bangladesh
sin embargo sanssouci negó las
acusaciones de genocidio los problemas
son periódicos entre las comunidades
musulmana y birmana en esta región es un
problema complejo que heredamos la líder
política continúa siendo una figura
popular en mianmar en noviembre de 2020
su partido volvió a conseguir una clara
victoria resultados que la junta
consideró fraudulentos con lo que
justificó el golpe militar de febrero